so for the plan for today
um we're gonna be talking about Better
Learning and first I'm going to recap a
little bit of what we talked about on
Monday with regard to the problem
formulation and the general recipe of
metal learning algorithms and then we're
going to actually get into approaches
for solving a few shot learning problems
uh and so this will cover what you'll be
implementing in homework one although
actually I think I saw a couple people
already turned in homework one so maybe
you've already implemented it
um and by the end of the lecture you'll
be able to implement few shot learning
algorithms and allow neural networks to
do the kind of few shot learning problem
that you did on the very first day of
class
cool um so let's get into a little bit
of the recap so on Monday we talked
about the metal learning problem where
our goal was that we were given some
data from some set of tasks and our goal
was to solve a new task with less data
at a higher level of accuracy or more
stabling
uh in the context of this course we'll
mostly be considering trying to learn
tasks more quickly that is with less
data than if we were training from
scratch
uh one of the key assumptions that I
mentioned is that the task should be
drawn from the same task distribution
this is an assumption that's needed to
show that these um these algorithms
might generalize to be able to learn new
tasks although of course in practice
it's a little bit difficult to sometimes
actually realize this assumption in
practice this is something that's
basically analogous to the standard IID
assumption that you see in machine
learning where you assume that you're
training data points and your test data
points are drawn from the same
distribution
um and so you might have some
distribution over tasks you're given
some trading tasks from that
distribution and a test task from that
dish
um like before we want the task to share
some structure and the task could
correspond to lots of different things
so in homework one the task will
correspond to recognizing handwritten
digits from different languages
um shown here
we'll also look at an example where
different tasks correspond to giving
feedback to students on different exam
problems or different assignments
um we'll look at one example where the
goal is different tasks correspond to
different regions of the world and you
might want to classify species in those
different regions of the world
and the task could also correspond to
something like robots performing
different tasks
um now a natural question to ask from
here is okay
we need a set of tasks in order to learn
a new task how many tasks do you need in
order to be able to quickly learn a new
task
there isn't really any cut and dry
answer here but in general the more the
better in machine learning the more data
you have the better off you'll be in
Better Learning the more tasks you have
the better off you'll be so essentially
in metal learning we're treating data
points uh as we're essentially treating
um treating tasks as data points
yeah
[Music]
is it like a new area of the
distribution that we haven't explored
understanding data set the house is
different from the normal thought that
we're facing on yeah so I guess
um we can draw an analogy to machine
learning where maybe we have a lot of
images taken from
um taken from the internet but then we
ultimately will want to pass in new
images into our machine learning model
and so those images don't match any of
the images that are in the training data
set
um here maybe
um as one example maybe different tasks
correspond to different users so you
want to build a spam classifier for
different users and then the test task
will be a new person and it'll be a
person that wasn't in the training data
set and we'll be trying to classify spam
versus real email for that particular
new user
does that make sense
so it'll be something that is um it
should be generally similar to the kinds
of things that you've seen before
because we want to
um that that's going to let us to that's
going to let us generalize to that new
task with a small amount of data but it
is going to be it can be something
that's that's new that's fundamentally
not seen in the training data set yeah
[Music]
essentially exploring some sort of like
some scene shape structure to use one
task to help you do the other
yeah so the question was um can metal
learning be used for two tasks that have
kind of seemingly uh very little in
common but perhaps maybe there is
something that they can discover that
they have in common so first if you only
train on two tasks then generalizing to
a third task will be very difficult but
that's I'm not sure that's exactly what
you're asking if some of the tasks in
your distribution are very different
from one another and you have more than
two tasks then meta learning will try to
find the the common structure between
them in a way that allows it to very
quickly
um solve those tasks uh and so yeah and
if there is shared structure then it's
explicitly going to optimize for trying
to find the things that are in common
between those tasks
yeah so in my case if there actually
isn't much shared structure would it be
like could it be detrimental it actually
is
better so if there isn't that much
shared structure would it be detrimental
to use meta learning
um
so I don't know if it necessarily be
detrimental in the sense that uh it may
be it may have a hard time finding that
shared structure
um
in the worst well I guess we'll get into
this when we get into the algorithms but
there are some algorithms where they
will essentially revert to learning from
scratch and so you won't do it worse
than learning from scratch whereas there
are some algorithms including the ones
that we'll talk about today where they
could do worse than learning from
scratch
yeah
um these are the data sets for each of
the tasks in the train set of about as
large as you would need and like a
normal machine learning password
yeah so one of the things that's really
cool about this is actually you can get
away with much less data per task than
if you were to train completely from
scratch uh and so we'll see this
actually in one of in one of the data
sets including actually the data set
that you'll use in your homework
cool so one of the things that we talked
about on Monday is that there's a couple
different ways that you can view meta
learning algorithms
um from one from a mechanistic
standpoint and one from a more
probabilistic standpoint and from the
mechanistic standpoint
um you can think of meta learning as
basically trying to train a neural
network to read as input data and give
you predictions for new data points uh
and so you can think of it as
implementing a learning procedure
whereas the more problems to view is
thinking about how we may try to learn a
prior extract prior knowledge from your
set of training tasks and impose that
prior at test time when trying to learn
so that you can learn with less data
um
in the next few lectures we're going to
really be focusing on The mechanistic
View which will make it easier to think
about how to actually Implement these
algorithms in practice but we'll come
back to the probabilistic view in um in
a few weeks
so um and then lastly the last thing
that we talked about on Monday was
looking at an example a few shot
classification example where ultimately
we wanted to be able to be able to
classify new examples shown on the right
here given a very small training data
set so the training data set only has
five data points and we want to be able
to use that training data set and
previous experience from other image
classes in order to effectively solve
and make predictions for new test
examples
and so the way that we can do this is uh
construct tasks that look a lot like
this test task so construct training
sets and test sets from other image
classes from other experience or data
that we might have
um
run kind of meta training on these on
these tasks such that when we see a new
task at meta test time we can learn from
this tiny data set and make predictions
now
and this is kind of an image
classification example we can consider
this for other machine learning problems
as well
um now what I'd like to talk about next
is first getting a little bit into some
of the terminology that's used in Better
Learning in the context of this example
and then we'll dive a little bit
um more into the setup
so
um we have the setup where we have a
number of different training tasks for
each of those tasks we have a training
data set and a test data set
um these are sometimes also called the
support set and the query set the
support set you can think of as kind of
providing support for the learning
process and then the query data set will
be used to query the predictions of the
model after learning on the support set
using this these ladder terminology can
be somewhat helpful to differentiate
between meta training and meta testing
um so we've talked about this notion of
few shot learning and so you can think
of this as k-shot learning where you
have K examples per class
um or if you're in a regression scenario
you have K examples total
so this is k-shot learning means you
essentially have K examples to learn
from
and then we'll
um consider we'll use n typically to
denote the number of classes that we're
trying to classify between the number of
classes that we're choosing between
so
um with that in mind I have a question
for you so maybe
um I want to ask you what is k n for
this example and so
first in terms of K maybe you can kind
of raise your fingers and kind of uh
say what you think actually let's
actually start with n so maybe raise
your hand with fingers to denote what
you think n is for this example
cool so I'm seeing a mixes mix of fives
and twos but mostly fives
cool so in this example we're doing NY
classification I guess so yeah the mix
of fives and twos is uh I can see where
you're coming from so
um I uh so
um this is a five-way example because we
have five different image classes
um shown in the left training data set
um I'm only showing two test examples
here just in terms of
um space on the slides uh but there are
kind of five classes underlying these
underlying these training data sets
and then can you put up a show of
numbers for what K is
I'm seeing ones uh which is good so yeah
we're giving it basically one example of
five different classes so this is a
One-Shot learning problem where you have
one example per class
uh and and we're trying to solve a
five-way classification problem
cool
um so that's a bit of the terminology
now
um
in terms of the uh the kind of
General recipe
um
or maybe another view on the metal
learning problem is uh if you think
about supervised learning our goal is to
map from inputs to outputs and to learn
a function that give predicts the input
predicts the output given the input and
we do this with a set of input output
pairs XY pairs
now in metal learning we can also
actually frame it as somewhat of a
supervised learning problem
where our inputs are going to be a
little bit different so our inputs are
actually going to include the training
data set for a task
as well as in that training data set
we'll have K examples okay examples per
class
and in addition to a training data set
for that task we're also going to have a
new test input that we want to be able
to make predictions for
so the training data says essentially
what was in the green box on the
previous slide and the test examples or
the test example is one of the things
that was in the blue box on the right
and then we want to be able to predict
the label for This Test example
and so you can think of this um this
green arrow here is the process of
learning from that data set to make a
prediction for a new example
and from this standpoint we could
actually again view this as a supervised
learning problem where you want to train
a neural network to take as input a data
set learn from that data set and make a
prediction on a new Test example
now um how do we go about learning this
this kind of function
well instead of having a data set of
input output pairs we're actually going
to have a data set of data sets
and each of these data sets has to have
at least has some more than K examples
so that you can sample K examples to be
used for the training data set and at
least one example to be used
for the test set
[Music]
of five different classes and actually
what you're actually classifying for are
two different classes
um yeah so going back to the the slide
here
um or this visualization here uh the
so the number of examples in these in
this red box here doesn't matter too
much this is um you well you need there
to be at least one example uh and you
need to be able to
um in general your test set is going to
be larger than two you'll probably have
um at least five examples
um in so that you're actually like
evaluating its ability to make
predictions for all five classes in your
trading data set
classification
um
oh um so I guess what I'm visualizing
here is a five shot classifier sorry a
five-way classification problem
and so you have one example for five
different classes and so it's it's a
One-Shot learning problem and then
technically if all you cared about was
to classify these two images then it's
actually a two-way classification
problem
um I I would have shown all five
examples if if I had a little bit more
space on the slides
um but yeah I'm trying to frame this as
a five-way problem
so you can sort of just think of this as
having uh like you can imagine if
there's like five examples here yeah
cool and here I'm actually only showing
one test example
um
uh in terms of like what this function
needs to produce but then when you
actually train this function you'll
actually sample more like different
different test examples um to evaluate
its ability to generalize given a given
a training example
or giving a training set
okay um and so we can learn this
function with a data set of data sets um
so a set of data sets where each data
set is for a particular task and again
this data set the data set for a given
task I should have more than K examples
so that you can use K to be used in the
training data set and some other
examples to be used in the in the test
set to measure generalization
yeah
there are two different
um like there are two different
subscripts here there is an eye and
there's so I corresponds to the test
the J is not
a number of examples okay yeah so here
are the is I is indexing the number of
tasks and J is indexing the examples
that we have within a task data set
cool um and so one way one thing that's
nice about this kind of view is it means
that
now
in order to implement a meta learning
algorithm all we have to do is
design this function f that can read his
input a data set and then optimize that
function f
and so essentially in this lecture in
the next two lectures we're going to be
talking about different ways that you
can design and optimize this function f
and so in particular kind of the general
recipe that you can think of for
designing a metal learning algorithm is
choosing a form of dysfunction
in this lecture we'll see a form of this
function where it's just represented by
a neural network but we'll actually see
other forms of this function in the
later lectures where F can correspond to
running gradient set or F could
correspond to an algorithm like nearest
Neighbors
and then once we have that function then
we're going to optimize the free
parameters of that function which we'll
refer to as the meta parameters
using the meta training data
[Music]
is the um is the
uh the test data for the task that is
specified by D train so x d train and X
test are both from the same task
um and so that could be if you're during
meditating time that's going to be one
of the meditating tasks if you're at
metatest time that's going to be one of
the new tasks that you haven't seen
before
yeah
um
so K is the number of examples like
you shot learning it's the number of
examples that you're going you're going
from
um
yeah actually so there's a question of
how do you choose k
um typically
if you have a sense for how many
um if you have a sense for like you want
to be able to do One-Shot learning then
you'll just set K to be
um essentially to be one per class
um and then at test time you'll do
One-Shot learning you could also have KB
variable so
um you could actually sample different k
for different tasks and have some tasks
be one shot learning tasks some tasks be
five shot learning tasks such that
you're preparing your network to be able
to do
um One Shot learning and five shot
learning at meta test time
yeah so the um the question was
shouldn't the index here be n times K
rather than K so if it is a
classification problem then it should be
n times k
um if it's a regression problem then the
standard notation is to just use K and
so I used K here but it kind of depends
if it's a regression or classification
problem
um and the reason the convention for
that is um One Shot learning you
typically think is learning from one
example and a regression
um in regression problems you can
actually well learning from one example
in regression probably you won't get
very far but it um that one shot
learning is learning from one example
there whereas in classification if you
have only one example it's it's
fundamentally impossible to solve like a
five-way problem with just one example
and so the kind of convention is to use
um
to have it be per class there and so if
this was classification the K would be n
times k
so foreign
basically corresponds to how many like
what is the size of the data set you're
passing into your function and
before
um well so basically you can train this
function to path to because input
variable size data sets and that's
useful because at test time if you're
not sure what size your data set's going
to be then your function should be able
to handle different sizes
yeah um during the last class when we
were talking about the probabilistic
view of metal learning the kind of
talked about
parameters representing the shared
structure and then also by which we're
against the task specific parameters so
in this case it's F representing both
you know and I or like is it just
representative data yeah so the the
parameters of the of f here are Theta
and that is kind of representing the um
the Theta that we saw in the previous
lecture
um here you don't see Phi up here here
and that's because Phi is
um we'll see in some algorithms Phi will
come out explicitly whereas in other
algorithms we won't be explicitly
representing Phi
um and so I it's useful to set up this
notation in a way that can either have
it or well that doesn't actually
explicitly represent it because some of
the algorithms we'll look at next week
don't actually explicitly represent what
Phi is
if it's not explicitly represented does
it just mean that it's like a part of
theta in some form or
sort of
um basically next week we'll cover non
like non-parametric meta learning
methods and so those don't actually have
explicit parameters and so
um Phi won't ever appear
um
it's but we'll get into that on
Wednesday next week
yeah
[Music]
um
so x-test is the is a new example uh
a new input uh for that um that task so
it's given a data set given a task data
set
um here we're gonna it'll basically just
correspond to one of the x's in the task
data set
cool so I think that we should start
kind of running into like approaches
because I think that will also clarify
the setup as well
um and so we're going to start with a
running example which is going to use
the Omni glot data set and you'll be
actually using this data set in your
homework it's actually a pretty cool
data set it has a data set of 50
different alphabets a written alphabets
and it has a total of 1623 characters
across all of those alphabets
and they're all written by hand by
people
and here are some examples of some of
the uh the alphabets represented in that
data set
um and per character there's actually
only 20 examples
so this is getting into one of the
questions which was mentioned before
which is that typically in a machine
learning data set you wouldn't have only
20 examples per class in your data set
uh for example
um in the mnist data set I think it has
like on the order of thousands of
examples uh maybe tens of thousands of
examples maybe like six thousand
examples per class I think
um as you can sort of think of this as
the transpose of a data set like mnist
where instead of having many examples
and a small number of classes you
actually have a large number of classes
and a very small number of examples per
class
um and I also think that the statistics
of this kind of data set are a little
bit more reflective of the real world
because uh in the real world we don't
see like
a thousand forks and a thousand
notebooks and a thousand pens and for
only a small number of things we
actually have a really massive number of
objects and we only
um kind of run into those objects uh a
small number of times in general
um cool so we're gonna be using this
data set and in this data set um to
start off we can think of different
tasks as different alphabets
and um
and uh let's think about how to actually
set up the kind of the metal learning
thing here so we're going to be looking
at a
a three-way classification problem just
because then I don't have to draw as
many uh images and we're going to be
looking at uh a One-Shot learning
problem
and
it's worth mentioning that there are two
different versions of block box meta
learning algorithms and so we'll cover
both of them
um
and first we'll talk about kind of the
meta training process so
the first thing to do uh
during meta training is to sample a task
and so this will correspond to sampling
an alphabet
and specifically sampling uh three
characters
from that alphabet and the reason why
it's three is because we're just going
to be considering a three-way
classification problem
and then once we've sampled a task uh
and sampled the characters that we're
going to be classifying between we're
going to sample
um two
images
uh per character
and
we're then going to break it these
examples into a train set and a test set
and so uh for example
maybe the alphabet that we sampled is uh
the alphabet that we use in English
and so
and the three characters that we sampled
were a b and c
and
we're going to sample two different
images per character so that we can use
uh
one for a training data set and one for
a test data set for that task
um so these are maybe uh yeah two
this is will be our kind of uh D train
for task I maybe be sampled task I
um and this is going to be d-test for
task guy
um now one thing that we're missing here
is we're also missing labels uh we need
labels in our train set and test set and
so what we're going to do is we're also
going to assign labels to each one of
these so we can say label 0 1 2 it's
important to have consistent labels
across our characters
okay
um and now we get to the fun part so
what we're going to do is we're going to
pass our training data set into a neural
network that will implement the learning
process
uh and so
um in terms of
passing this into a neural network these
data sets may have a number of different
examples and so things like a recurrent
neural network are typically a good
choice
um or or a Transformer if you want to be
a little more
into the times and so
you'll pass this into
your chain data points into a recurrent
neural network
and at this point we're going to get to
kind of the two different versions so
one version of Black Box meta learning
will take us and put these training data
points and output
a set of parameters
and we'll then use those set of
parameters to classify new examples from
our test set
and so in particular we will
I'm going to
work on my Space Management so
um we'll take these set of parameters
we'll then pass this input one of our
test examples into a neural network with
those parameters to get a prediction
for that test example so this will be X
test I this will be y hat test I
and then we'll compare this to the
corresponding label
for
that example
and then what we can do is we can once
we compare our prediction for this
example to the label for that example we
can back propagate through this entire
neural network into the parameters to
train this neural network so that it can
learn how to learn from this data set
cool and then once we then kind of back
propagate into the neural network update
the parameters of this network here
which will be the parameters Theta will
then kind of this is step three then
we'll go back to Step One sample another
task and iterate the process
so this is the The Meta training process
um
we can talk a little bit about the
metatest process before we move on to
um
before I move on to uh the second
version but yeah
um
um does it go through the neural network
or does it go through the neural network
and the classification
um so it's basically going to update all
of the parameters of this of this
network
um and one actually one really really
important thing to note is that it's not
going to update Phi
um so Phi you can think of more as an
activation of this neural network
it is only going to update the meta
parameters of of this network
um so we're going to differentiate
through Phi into the parameters of this
thing right here I really should have
brought some more colors today but you
can think of the parameters the
parameters of this will include like
both the encoder as well as
um kind of the the um
the uh kind of recurrent parameters as
well
yes the question is why does it make
sense to use a recurrent neural network
um you can use other networks as well
and we'll talk about some other choices
you could use something like a deep set
architecture or a Transformer one thing
that is convenient about sequence models
in general is that they can handle
variable length sequences and so you can
um
you can pass in like variable length
data sets for example and it should be
able to handle that in general
architectures for handling sets and
sequences are are pretty good choices
yeah
like four classes
yeah the question is if you do
um Mediterranean with three classes and
then evaluate this ability to learn with
four classes then how well does that
work uh in general probably not very
well it depends on the architecture
choice that you choose but
um if I mean you're basically training a
recurrent neural network and if you if
you train a recurrent neural network on
a sequence like the three and then test
it on a sequence like the four you're
basically testing it on something that
it hasn't been trained to do
yeah
do you need it has to do that for your
training tasks or can you do this in an
unsuper device
yeah so the question is do you need test
data and can you do this in an
unsupervised way
um
there's lots of different variations
that you could consider here you could
consider something where the trained
data set is maybe unlabeled
um and is trying to to like it but the
test set is labeled for example and is
trying to
cluster and so forth we'll get into some
more advanced kind of variations of this
in some of the coming lectures
uh but in the
well yeah in the basic setup it's good
to have labels are helpful
um the other thing that I'll say is it
is important for these to be held out
examples
um and not just the same examples as
what you pass in because if you pass in
exactly the same exam this example here
instead of learning to learn it will
learn to memorize and it will learn to
just exactly only be able to make
predictions for
um the examples that you passed in
one other note that I should mention
here is that
um here note that we're passing in both
X and Y we're passing in both the the
input and the label
um into the recurrent neural network uh
here it's important not to pass in the
label
uh because if you pass in the label then
uh it will just uh not look at the image
and predict the label and this is um
something that you'll run into in their
homework uh it's a kind of common
mistake to accidentally pass in the
label into the network here
isn't that the two biggest of us yeah so
one downside of using an RNN is that the
secret The Ordering of these data points
matters and in practice
this is a this is a set and so the order
of examples doesn't matter
um we'll get to this in a few slides but
the um architectures that like deep sets
that are permutation invariant are
actually can be a better choice than an
RNN for that reason because they'll
encode the fact that the ordering of the
data points doesn't matter
[Music]
yeah so here it is actually it's here
it's predicting parameters that are
being used to make predictions and so
um this is a in general a uh a pretty
high dimensional vector and so it may
correspond to like yeah the parameters
of a neural network
um I guess I'll get into version two so
that was like
this was version one
um
version two uh is something that is a
little bit uh
a little bit less unwieldy so predicting
like millions of parameters with a
neural network can be rather expensive
and so what you can do instead
[Music]
um
is
um let me write these out again you
don't have the label for this so what
you can do instead is you can simply uh
thank you
use something like a recurrent neural
network and actually just continue
running that that recurrent neural
network uh here
and in this case
the Phi I is more implicit
and here you'll be tell you'll again be
asking it to predict uh why I test for
this example right here which is X I
test
and this is something where you don't
actually have to have your RNN output a
huge parameter Vector you can just have
it output say the this is like the
hidden state of your RNN after after
like three examples
uh and you can sort of think of uh Phi I
as like the set of um the kind of
the set of like these hidden parameters
as well as any parameters that are in uh
this network right here um so we can
maybe refer to this as like Theta G in
the sense that if this is like a
function G uh
those are the parameters of that
function and so
um this is what like Phi I would be in
that case uh in this case this is a lot
nicer because
um and this is going to be used more in
practice than this version because uh
then you don't have to Output like
millions of parameters of a network you
can actually
um
yeah you can actually like only
represent a much smaller context here
[Music]
so in this lecture the top specific
parameters are the output of this neural
network model
um here or
um or or here I guess we can call this h
i in the sense that this is kind of a um
a context Vector in the lecture on
Monday we'll see examples where the top
specific parameters are the results of
something else like running an
optimization like gradient descent
one
why is it important to
people
yeah so the question is um why is it
important to not update Phi I so
the um
I think that maybe so in this example it
may be a little bit more clear in the
sense that uh when we run gradient
descent on to kind of test
generalization in this case we're going
to back prop into all of the parameters
of this RNN but we're not going to
update hi because hi is an activation
and when you have activations of a
neural network you don't update the
activations you only update the weights
um and so analogously in this example
you can think of Phi I as the
activations of your neural network
um and so you're not going to be
updating that you're only going to be
updating the weights of this neural
network
yeah you should see one more time with
the differences between one and two yeah
so the difference
version one and version two is
um
similar the main difference is that in
this case
um this neural network right here the
only parameters
making predictions from this example to
why tests are going to be Phi I and
those are going to be outputted by this
and so those are going to be the
activations of this RNN whereas in this
case some of the parameters are actually
going to be
um some of the parameters here are
actually going to be
optimized as part of the meta
optimization
and so for example uh the the encoder of
this RNN may actually be shared across
the time steps uh and so you basically
have more parameter sharing in this
version
um so
the
you're asking
um
[Music]
yeah so in this case Theta G will also
be will be optimized um with back prop
as well but hi will not be uh
the training like sequence it'll be
optimized with respect to this
um the loss here
is
um you can basically like think of all
of this as the learning process and
we're optimizing all the parameters of
this learning process with respect to
how well it generalizes on a new Test
example
um the one thing that you may be
noticing here is that it could be that
the neural network could just ignore all
of this and just like learn a classifier
for it and that's actually a problem
that can come up in meta learning
uh and so one thing that I'll mention
here is that the um
here we kind of we assigned labels
somewhat arbitrarily like zero one two
like in the order of the alphabet but
really that was somewhat arbitrary and
when you're given a new alphabet you
don't know what is the first letter of
the alphabet versus the second versus
the third and so what we'll do in
practice is um when we assign these
labels we'll assign them randomly and so
when we sample a task
um in this case I I assign this this
labeling but and when you sample this
task the next time you might sample a
different labeling where you have for
example one two zero one two zero and as
a result when you actually randomize
that that prevents the neural network
from just memorizing a mapping from the
uh from the input to the label and
ignoring the the context foreign
like similar to hi here Phi is is an
activation of the neural network rather
than
um rather than some of the weights
um so it's it's the output of this it is
the parameters of a neural network but
it's the output of of our of our
recurrent neural network
um and so we're setting it to be the
output of this neural network uh and so
if you updated it one round then the
next round it would just be wiped by a
forward pass of the RNN
yeah
could it be because of the because in my
life changing the regime of training is
very different from the normal training
that is
trade even in trading we have two subset
of for each class
which is like training and testing so
although it is said to be testing labor
testing data it's not actually testing
data we use it to train our model
yeah that's a great point so to kind of
reiterate
um when I'm talking about this this is
like our our task test set
um
for for task I and we are going to be
training
the parameters of our RNN with these
test examples and that may sound like a
really bad thing and it sort of should
sound like a really bad thing because
we're going to be training on these test
sets
um but in Med learning actually the real
test is new tasks so
um this is the test set of the training
task or one of the training tasks and
then we're going to be given new test
tasks and those are going to be the
really the real test for this uh for
these models
[Music]
so the question was is there a risk of
catastrophic forgetting in this case
um of past tasks that you've seen so
um in practice when we sample tasks
we'll stamp the sample them from a set
of tasks and as long as you keep on
sampling from that task IID then you
should be able to remember those tasks
um
I should also mention here um I said
that we're just going to sample one task
in practice you can sample a mini batch
of tasks so multiple tasks and that will
give you a lower variance gradient
um and so similar to like in machine
learning if you're sampling IID from a
training data set you don't have to
worry too much about forgetting
um we also don't have to worry about
that too much here but if we did have a
sequence like a non-stationary sequence
of tasks we might start forgetting some
of the older tasks if they don't keep on
reoccurring
[Music]
foreign
so you want to have some sort of network
the question is why not why are we using
an RNN versus some other sort of network
you do want this network to be able to
take a Zen put a data set uh and
data sets um do you want to be able to
process some sort of set of examples
um and so things like rnns are a good
choice for modeling well they're
actually not in practice they're not a
great choice but they're the simplest
choice for modeling sequences and things
like Transformers and deep set
architectures and like 1D convolutions
could also be used as well you wouldn't
want to use like a feed forward well so
one thing you could do is you could use
a feed forward fully connected Network
and basically concatenate the embeddings
concatenate all these images together
and pass it through that way and that
might not be a great choice uh be
compared to something that explicitly
models these as separate entities
foreign
[Music]
one work with very high dimensional Phi
so uh there are some some papers that
have actually gotten it to work pretty
well uh in practice people typically use
some form of sharing across layers so
that you're not outputting the entire
parameter Vector all at once you might
be outputting like one layer at a time
uh maybe telling the network which layer
that it might be outputting
um one paper or one thing that this is
often referred to is a hyper Network
uh and a hyper network is basically any
sort of neural network that's outputting
the weights of another neural network uh
and
uh and it can be used for metal learning
but it can also be used for other things
uh and so there are some examples of it
working well uh but also in general for
a few shot learning problems this is the
more practical solution
cool
um I have a couple examples of other
data sets on the slides if you're
interested in exploring that for your
project
um but for now I just want to oh
actually I want to recap some of the
stuff on the Whiteboard but also
um we've talked about meta training we
haven't explicitly gone through what
meta test time looks like so let's also
quickly do that first so
at metatest time
um
you're actually just given a a test task
and you're also given
a training data set
for that test task
and so for example maybe your data set
is of the Greek alphabet and so you have
some examples
like this
and then you're probably also given uh
some test examples so maybe you're given
a
an example that looks like this and you
want to be able to classify this example
given your few trading examples
and so
does anyone anyone want to kind of say
what we might do at metatest time
foreign yeah so what we can do is we can
pass our training data set into our
recurrent neural network also passes
input our test example
um and asks it what the corresponding
label is so
um we'll probably be given corresponding
labels for this like 0 1 and 2 and we
will pass these into
our neural network doesn't have to be an
RNN
and then also
passes input this example and then
hopefully the neural network will output
zero insofar as that looks like a
in Alpha
well so for the training safety
investors we have to make multiple
sources
and then try on the second
in our XPS
so in Black Box meta learning what
you'll do is you'll always pass in the
whole training data set is input and
then pass in the test example
um one version another method that we'll
see next week is something that actually
makes explicit comparisons between the
test example and the training examples
does that answer your question
um
sorry can you repeat that
happening
yeah so the question was is there any
like
um parameter updates or any tuning
that's happening when we do this uh an
answer is no so we're just doing a
forward pass through this RNN uh and so
we're not actually you can think of this
RNN as kind of implementing the learning
process and if you give it a big enough
neural network these neural networks can
can learn in that way
um
and so there isn't actually any sort of
uh parameter updating other than perhaps
you can sort of think of the Hidden
State as being updated as you pass it
through the recurrent neural network
[Music]
so you're asking why not why why not
have an algorithm that does do some
amount of time
see that on Monday next week
yeah so here the RN is predicting the
bottom of this is
this some kind of model that is
that would depend on like the kind of
model that we have right today
generally for version one the
architecture of this function right here
will be always the same it will be fixed
well some kinds of applications are easy
required to learn files are easier to
learn the critics
yeah if you're asking is there are there
some architectures for which should be
easier to predict Phi than others
um
generally the smaller the architecture
the easier uh yeah
um and if you only have to predict some
of the parameters of the architecture
which is similar to here like for
example you could have it only output
like H could correspond to like the last
the last layer of this network and then
you
um you only have to predict like some
part of it for example
so I'm calling this black box metal
learning because the learning process
itself is uh somewhat of a black box is
just this big neural network I guess
it's multiple boxes on the board but you
can think of this as just one kind of
Monolithic neural network and we don't
have a lot of uh we don't see a lot of
what happens inside this neural network
to actually interpret how it's actually
adapting or learning from these examples
uh once the hyper Network produced by
eye is
like
um so
um it outfits it once and then we make
predictions with that and so we can
predict this example but and also make
predictions for the other test examples
and it will only be changed once we pass
in a new training data set
[Music]
what is the neural network doing
um
I don't have a because this is Black Box
I don't have a great sense for exactly
how I'm practiced the neural network is
is implementing it is choosing to
implement this
um it does have to store information
about how you map images to labels and
and like what what is it like
zero what does label zero mean from an
image
um
or it could be I mean it could there's a
lot of things that it it could be doing
it could be uh actually like if it's a
really huge neural network it could be
mimicking something kind of like
gradient descent for example
um so it's a little bit uh hard to
understand in general
yeah
three more questions on uh
classes
[Music]
yeah so the question is is there a way
to tell if certain character classes or
certain tasks would be helpful in
um for a particular test task
s of languages
yeah so if you have a ton tons of tasks
um then it yeah there's going to be kind
of more heterogeneity in terms of when
when toss might be helpful for the test
task
um but yeah in general uh it we don't
really know it's kind of similar to
fine-tuning and multiple uh and maybe
you should figure it out for your
project and then tell us all how to do
it
um cool so
I went through a lot of that on the
Whiteboard because I felt like that
would be easier and kind of more
intuitive to walk through
um the slides have basically everything
that we went through on the Whiteboard
so
um version one we're gonna be training a
neural network to Output these
parameters and then we're going to be
predicting test data points using a
neural network parametrized by those
parameters by I mean you could think of
the first Network as kind of the
Learners learning from these training
data points and the second Network as
something that's actually making
predictions using those parameters
um here's here's the RNN that we drew on
the board
um this is representing F Theta um and
then here's the kind of the second part
of the network that we draw on the board
as well
um from the test examples and then we
can train this train the parameters of
theta with standard supervised learning
um in terms of what the loss function
looks like uh log negative log
likelihood
um is which is cross-entropy loss or
mean squared error is that the loss
function that's typical to use for
supervised learning
um and so that's
basically the loss function that will be
applied right here to back propagate
through
um
and you can if you think about this as
the loss function for task I uh then you
can basically view uh kind of this
overall loss function as making a
prediction for task guide and then
evaluating that on the test data points
for task I
um and then averaging that across the
tasks
um I want to go through this somewhat
quickly because this is basically stuff
that we all went through on the board
um we sample a task we can also sample a
mini batch of tasks rather than just one
task
um we can then sample disjoint data sets
so this would be like our trading set
and our test data set from all of the
examples that we have for a particular
task
I should mention maybe here that uh it's
worthwhile to kind of mix and match
these so you shouldn't always use this
as your test examples and always use
this as your trading examples you can
get a little bit more data for meta
training by randomly sampling what you
use as a training example and what you
use as a test example
and so kind of visually what this looks
like is maybe these are all the examples
you have for one of your tasks
um you want to allocate this into
training examples and test examples and
so you'll kind of just randomly assign
them to a train set and do a test set
um cool and then once you have your
train set and test set you can compute
uh the parameters and then update
um compute the parameters with the
forward pass and then update the um the
meta parameters with the backward pass
and then repeat
[Music]
um
cool uh we talked about how outputting
all the neural network parameters isn't
very scalable and so instead of doing
that you can just only output the
sufficient statistics and use another
um basically replace Phi I with hi and
have this be a lower dimensional vector
and how that can be combined with some
other meta parameters in order to make a
prediction
um one thing that's kind of intuitively
nice about this low dimensional Vector
is you can think of it as representing
contextual task information
and so if we remember back to multitask
learning where we had this task
descriptor zi I could sort of think of
hi as a form of task descriptor that
we're inferring from data
and then we're just going to be passing
that hi into a neural network in order
to make predictions for that task
yeah
to make sure it's
um effective at uh working on path
because they might be fight different so
how do you know that your tasks test
tasks that is a good representation of
how alone would do on another
random account yeah so the question is
how many test tasks should we use when
we're evaluating a meta learning
algorithm
um and so yeah in general you don't want
to just have one target task when you're
evaluating you want to have like at
least a few uh and one thing that you
can do to get a sense for
um how many you need is you can look at
the variance of the accuracy across
tasks and so if one task you're seeing
it has
um like 80 accuracy another task has 100
accuracy and another task is like zero
percent accuracy then your variance is
pretty large whereas if they seem to be
more or less consistent across tasks
that that maybe is a good indication
that you may have enough tasks
to get a good reading on it
yeah
yeah so question was how do we learn the
big Theta G for um for five eyes so
um you can think of theta G as part of
the meta parameters and so that's
actually why I'm using the Theta here so
we're going to optimize Theta G
alongside all of the rest of the
parameters of theta
um
and so that's that's how we allow that's
how we make it possible to have HIV only
a low dimensional Vector likewise Theta
G may have some parameters that are
shared with um with the kind of the
other part of the recurrent neural
network because for example you may have
like the encoder of the image be the
same for the these training examples and
test examples
yeah is there a ballpark for how much
less data that you need for each task
with my learning versus electronicated
individual model
yeah so is there a ballpark for how much
data
um you need so
with meta training and as you'll see in
the assignment you can go down to as few
as one example per class if you have a
lot of tasks uh and so
the per task you can go down is
um to something very very small if you
have a lot of tasks and if they have
shared structure uh that said if you
only have one example per class you're
still gonna get your total amount of
data may still be somewhat similar to
um
to kind of single task learning in that
you um you may have a lot of tasks and
so you may have a small amount of
examples per task but a lot of different
tasks so your total data may be somewhat
similar
um and then of course the amount of data
you need will depend a little bit on the
complexity of the problem you're solving
cool
um
and then I thought I would talk a little
bit about architectures so we talked a
little bit about rnns before
um one of the first papers that
introduced this at least more modern
notion of meta learning with kind of
block box neural networks is this paper
right here
um and this is from 2016 this is
actually sort of in response to a
challenge basically the omnigot
challenge being released and some
cognitive scientists saying neural
networks can't do few shot learning uh
newspaper showed that oh neural networks
can actually do for you shot learning
um and and was able to do pretty well on
on the omnilot data set they used lstms
and neural Turing machines I wouldn't
necessarily recommend using neural
Turing machines or I think a little bit
of a relic of the past uh but
um yeah it's worth mentioning this is
one of the first papers uh and in your
homework I believe we have you using
lstms in the homework but if you want to
you can also play around a little bit
with Transformers
um another architecture which is called
a deep set architecture is to instead of
having a recurrent neural network
instead pass all of your examples
through a feed forward neural network to
get an embedding of each of your images
and then average those embeddings to get
a kind of a summary vector
I sort of already answered this earlier
but I guess I can see if you're paying
attention which is um why would
something like feed forward and an
average be better than our current
neural network
yeah so it's permutation invariance so
um yeah so averaging
is agnostic to the order of the things
that you're averaging and so this sort
of Architecture is permutation invariant
um one thing that this is an
architecture called Deep sets one thing
that's actually pretty cool about deep
sets is there's a result that shows that
um for some conditions on the width and
depth of the network these kinds of
architectures can represent any
permutation invariant function and so
while it may seem actually somewhat
limiting these architectures are
actually very expressive as long as you
only care about permutation and variant
functions
um there's also other external memory
mechanisms that have been proposed
um and then this um
there's also papers that have proposed
things that use attention and
convolution
um this paper came out before the before
I think Transformers
um or certainly before Transformers were
popular and so they probably would have
called it a Transformer or something and
then there's probably more recent papers
that that actually use things like
Transformers as well
um and then these methods can do pretty
well so on the Omni glot data set uh if
you use this this architecture which
uses attention and convolutions
interleaved
um on Omniglot on five-way one shot
omnigot you can get 99 accuracy
um if you have five examples you can get
even higher 99.78 accuracy
if you make it a little bit harder and
you're now doing a 20-way classification
problem then you can still get
accuracies in the high 90s
um so Omniglot is uh is uh not too
difficult and then if you look at
something like mini imagenet which is a
smaller version of imagenet with smaller
images
you can start to get somewhat reasonable
one shot and five shot accuracy but
these numbers are a lot lower than Omni
lot numbers uh and
they're also
um
certainly below state of the art uh yeah
but we'll see some things that are
closer to state of the art in the uh in
the next two lectures
so
yeah
external memory systems
um
I don't think that they are necessarily
things like neural Turing machines and
these other external memory mechanisms I
guess I wouldn't necessarily recommend
them
um I think that they're possibly
interesting from like a neuroscience
standpoint because
um
I guess I'm not a neuroscientist so
maybe I shouldn't talk about this but I
think that there are aspects of the
brain that kind of store memories uh and
so if you want to think about kind of
key value storage and kind of storing
things in that way these things may be
interesting uh they also perhaps have
some benefits from the standpoint of
um
uh
from the standpoint of um
like maybe kind of memory footprint
because if you can very efficiently
store that information then maybe you
don't need kind of this really big
Transformer but we haven't seen that's
something speculative and we really
haven't seen
um a lot of benefits empirically from
using them
cool um so I'm in homework one
um there's gonna be some key things that
you're the two key things that you'll do
is implement the data processing so
Implement how do you actually like split
things up into tasks and examples per
tasks and then also Implement a pretty
simple Black Box metal learner and train
dot on Omni lot and get some results
cool
um so
in terms of just kind of also sum things
up um and talk about some of the pros
and cons of this approach
one thing that's really nice about these
kind this kind of approach to metal
learning is that these big neural
networks are quite expressive and they
can represent lots of different learning
procedures rnns can represent
um
if they're large enough they can
represent really any function
they're also really easy to combine with
a variety of problems
today we talked about supervised
learning where you back propagate the
loss with a supervised objective but
it's also very easy to plug this into
reinforcement learning objectives as
well because maybe it's outputting not
the label but an action or a q value and
you can train this just like you would
train a recurrent neural network
um with kind of reinforcement learning
objectives
um in terms of the downsides
um
these big networks are somewhat complex
and they have to learn something pretty
difficult which is learning from data
data points and this can lead to
somewhat of a challenging optimization
problem and as we'll start to see in
some of the next lectures uh
optimizing like trying to learn how to
learn from scratch from kind of randomly
randomly initialized RNN weights can be
pretty difficult in comparison to giving
it some of the structure of learning
algorithms that we already know
um and so as a result because it's a
hard optimization these can be uh less
data efficient than other Med learning
approaches
cool
um so
there are other ways that we can
represent F Theta and so
next time on Monday we'll talk about
what if we treat f as an optimization
problem and actually embed optimization
into F rather than having this Big R net
cool
um so now I'd like to talk a little bit
about
um large language models and things like
gpt3 chinchilla and and the latest
gopher Palm the biggest language models
these days uh
and we're going to focus on dpt3 just
because it's a fairly canonical example
uh and they also have lots of really
cool uh qualitative examples in the
paper that we can draw from
and things like gbt3 are a lot like uh
kind of a black box neural network but
one thing that's a little bit different
from here that we'll talk about is that
they have
that the future learning kind of emerges
uh in a way that wasn't explicitly
uh
I think that when you train a language
model with a language modeling objective
you're not kind of setting out for a few
shot learning you're not setting up the
data to train it to do few shot learning
it's something that kind of emerges uh
from the data in a somewhat more
surprising way and so we'll talk a
little bit about emergent versus the
kind of future learning we see here
um so gpt3 is a language model
um you can sort of think of it as a
black box meta learner or a kind of a
big RNN
uh well Transformer neural network
that's trained on language generation
tasks
and you could sort of think of it as uh
where D train corresponds to a sequence
of characters
and detest corresponds to the following
sequence of characters
and so D train is what the language
model is being conditioned on and detest
is what it's being trained to generate
um the data set corresponds to crawl
data from the internet English like
English language Wikipedia and two book
corporas
and the architecture is a a very large
well I guess by these standards but
these days it might be considered
somewhat small but um in my my opinion a
somewhat large uh transport or neural
network
um and so it has 175 billion parameters
96 layers
um and a pretty large baptize
um what are the different tasks
correspond to so this is something that
uh this is where kind of emergent fuse
shot learning comes into play so
um you can
see it do tasks like spelling
Corrections simple math problems
translating between languages and these
tasks are in some ways somewhat emergent
but also in some ways reflective of the
kind of data that you see on the
internet
um
and the cool thing about things like
language models is that these seem like
in like on the surface these seem like
very different tasks
uh like math versus machine translation
versus spelling uh and we could actually
have all these tasks solved by a single
architecture
so
um the way that you can do that is to
put them all in the form of text put
them all in kind of a common
language for the network
and that's a good idea because it's also
very easy to get a lot of data of text
on the internet
um and so what this looks like is you
have an inner loop and an outer loop so
um in here kind of a forward pass of our
RNN was an inner loop and training that
RN to learn was our Outer Loop and so
likewise here in context learning uh
kind of running the RNN on text is your
inner loop and then across when you see
um
uh across tasks and optimizing the
neural network across to these different
tasks is uh is the outer loop and that's
kind of the learning process of
optimizing the parameters of your big
Transformer model
um and so these are kind of the example
tasks that we saw before all in text
form
um
cool and so they trained this on on data
from the internet and Wikipedia and so
forth and you can get some pretty cool
results so you can see something like
one shot learning where you give it a
dictionary definition saying to Screech
something is to swing a sword at it an
example of a sentence that uses the word
Screech is and then it gives you a
sentence we screeched at each other for
several minutes and then we went outside
and ate ice cream
um so this is like one example of
One-Shot learning um you could also do
few shot language editing where here you
give it a
five-ish examples of uh poor English
versus good English and once you give it
those examples and then give an example
of poor English input I'd be more than
happy to work with you in another
project the good English output that
corresponds to that that it gives you is
I'd be more than happy to work with you
on another project
um and likewise you see another example
for the same prompt
um the bottom
and then it can also do things that
aren't really considered future learning
tasks so you can ask it to write an
article for you given a title and a
subtitle
cool
um so some things about gpg3 is that the
results are really impressive and also
since gbt3 has come out there's actually
some models that do even better by a
pretty significant margin
um gbt3 and other more recent models are
also far from perfect they they make
mistakes so gpt3 itself even the largest
model has an accuracy around 50 to 60
percent on a few shot learning tasks I
think that some of I think that things
like chinchilla are maybe closer to like
high 70s
but still
uh have a lot of room for improvement
they also fail in somewhat unintuitive
ways so uh if you ask uh it how many
eyes does a draft have you draft has two
eyes how many eyes does my foot have uh
it starts telling you things like your
foot has two eyes
um and a spider has eight eyes and so
forth so
um
yeah there's uh it doesn't fail in the
same way that humans fail
um the last note here is that the choice
of D train like basically how you prompt
the model how you give it these examples
is also quite important and we'll see an
example of this you'll get a play around
with this a little bit in uh in homework
three
um and then the last thing I wanted to
mention about these models is that
there's some recent research on actually
trying to understand when will fuchsia
learning emerge
um from these data from these these
kinds of models that are trained on Text
data
and they the research has shown that
both aspects of the data and the model
is important so this has shown that
um having temporal correlation in the
data is important and for example if D
train and detest are completely
independent from one another they won't
actually learn to use that context and
it will just ignore that context
uh and so um they think of this as kind
of having a kind of bursty data in in
Time versus non-versity data
um they also find that having a dynamic
meaning of words is helpful if there's a
word that kind of means different things
in different contexts like the the word
Wicked might mean uh something like evil
in one context and something like really
cool in another context uh and that can
help with few shot learning because that
encourages the model to um to actually
pay attention to the context when making
future predictions
um and then also there's some work
suggesting that different aspects of the
model are important the biggest number
one thing is that the model has a high
capacity
um people have found that Transformers
are much better at giving you capacity
than things like lstms and rnns and so
um here's a plot of kind of future
learning accuracy
for these different architectures and
then also larger Transformers are better
than smaller Transformers in the gpt3
paper
um they showed that like a 175 billion
parameter model was much better at few
shot learning than some of these smaller
models
cool
um so yeah that was uh it for today uh
we went over Black Box meta learning and
saw how we can train neural networks to
do few shot learning
um as a couple reminders your project
group form is due on Monday and homework
one is due on Wednesday next week